in this video I'm going to explain all
the core Technologies you need to learn
to become a front-end developer my name
is Bo KS and I've created many courses
about frontend development for the freec
camp.org YouTube channel you can learn a
lot from this video on its own but it
also serves as an introduction to a
massive curriculum that will teach you
every technology I talk about in detail
each week we publish a lot of content on
the freec camp.org YouTube channel and
new people some times wonder where to
start and what order to watch the
courses well if you want to become a
front developer this is where to start
this is our front-end developer road map
we've curated a collection of top-notch
courses on all of the key Technologies
you need to learn and you can watch them
all right here on our Channel for free
I'll start with explaining what
front-end development actually is
front-end development is like designing
the face of a website or app app it's
all about how things look and feel when
you use them while back in developers
make sure everything works behind the
scenes front-end developers focus on
what you see and interact with making
sure it's easy to use and looks good on
any device in short frontend developers
turn designs into live websites and apps
that people can use at its core frontend
development revolves around three main
Technologies HTML CSS and JavaScript
I'll explain more about these
Technologies in a bit but for now just
know that almost everything in front end
development revolves around them as a
front end developer Your Role is pivotal
and ensuring that the website's design
translates well to various devices is
userfriendly and aligns with the
client's Vision you may be wondering how
long it takes to become a front-end
developer the journey to becoming a
front-end developer is unique for
everyone for complete beginners it might
take anywhere from between 6 to 12
months of dedicated learning and
practice to land in entry-level position
for those with some prior knowledge the
timeline might be shorter the key is
consistent practice engagement with the
developer community and continuous
learning this front-end road map covers
a lot of important tools and
Technologies not every item on this road
map is essential for entry into the
field every job is unique and most of
the jobs will require a subset of the
Technologies on the road map the most
important things to know are HTML CSS
and JavaScript but remember the tech
world is ever evolving and staying
updated is crucial this road map will
help you identify areas you might need
to explore further so here are the
essential Technologies you need to learn
you can watch a full comprehensive
course on each of these Technologies
right here on the freec camp.org YouTube
channel before diving into the
intricacies of front-end development
it's essential to grasp the foundational
concepts of how the internet functions
this foundational knowledge encompasses
standing domains the domain name system
servers and protocols like HTTP
additionally a basic comprehension of
web browsers their role and how they
render web pages is crucial for anyone
looking to venture into web development
some people may already have an
understanding of these Concepts and can
move on to other topics HTML or
hypertext markup language is the
Cornerstone of web content it's kind of
like the skeleton of a website providing
the essential structure of upon which
everything else is built as a standard
markup language for web pages HTML uses
tags to Define elements and structure
the content from headings to paragraphs
links and images everything visible on a
web page is typically structured using
HTML when writing HTML JavaScript or
other code it's helpful to use a code
editor in the realm of code editors
Visual Studio code stands out as a
favorite among developers though there
are some other ones as well it's more
than just a simple text editor it offers
a bunch of features including syntax
highlighting a range of extensions for
added functionalities and an integrated
terminal if HTML is the skeleton of a
website CSS or cascading stylesheets is
its skin it's responsible for the visual
appeal of a website dictating everything
from colors and fonts to layouts CSS
allows developers to create responsive
designs that adapt to different screen
sizes and devices it ensures that
websites are not only functional but
also aesthetically pleasing and
userfriendly JavaScript breathes life
into static web pages it's a dynamic
programming language that introduces
interactivity making websites more
engaging and user Centric from simple
animations to complex functionalities
like form validations and asynchronous
data fetching JavaScript plays a pivotal
role it's the magic behind the dynamic
behavior of web application
to maximize your productivity as a
developer it's important to understand
how to use large language models such as
chat GPT Bard and others a knowledge of
prompt engineering will help you
understand how to get the most helpful
responses from large language models and
in case you're wondering yes frontend
developers will still be needed in the
future even with Technologies like chap
GPT the workflow may be different but
there will be a human element required
for the foreseeable future in the world
of software development tracking and
managing changes is crucial this is
where Version Control Systems
particularly git come into play git
allows developers to track changes
collaborate seamlessly and revert to
previous versions if needed GitHub on
the other hand is a platform that hosts
git repositories facilitating
collaboration code sharing and even
deployment as projects grow and evolve
managing software libraries and
dependency can become a challenge
package managers are tools designed to
address this challenge popular package
managers like mpm or yarn help
developers manage install and update
software libraries seamlessly they
ensure that projects have the right
versions of dependencies making the
deployment process smoother designing
responsive and Visually appealing
websites can be streamlined with the
right tools bootstrap is one such CSS
framework that has revolutionized web
design design bootstrap offers
predesigned components and a grid system
making responsive design a breeze SAS is
a CSS pre-processor it allows for
Advanced Styling techniques variables
and nested rules enhancing The Styling
process modern web applications demand
efficiency scalability and
maintainability JavaScript Frameworks in
libraries provide pre-written code to
support these requirements Frameworks
like react View VI angular and others
have their own philosophies and
methodologies but aim to simplify
complex tasks promote code reusability
and enhanced performance they play a
pivotal role in building single page
applications and dynamic web apps
Tailwind CSS has emerged as a game
changer in the world of CSS Frameworks
it adopts a utility first approach
allowing for Rapid UI development
instead of predefined components
Tailwind provides utility classes that
can be combined to create custom designs
this approach promotes flexibility and
reduces the need for custom CSS leading
to faster development Cycles as web
applications become more complex the
need for efficient build tools becomes
evident these tools optimize bundle and
serve our code ensuring that
applications run smoothly Vite for
instance is a Next Generation front-end
tooling solution that offers fast fter
build times such tools handle tasks like
transpilation minification and module
bundling ensuring that the code is
optimized for production ensuring the
reliability and functionality of web
applications is Paramount this is where
JavaScript testing tools come into play
tools like jest designed for unit
testing and Cyprus tailored for into in
testing help developers ensure that
their code functions as intended regular
testing minimizes bugs and enhances the
overall quality of web applications
while JavaScript is dynamic and flexible
there are scenarios where a more
structured approach is beneficial enter
typescript a subset of JavaScript that
introduces static typing typescript
offers type annotations interfaces and
enhanced tooling leading to more robust
code it helps catch errors during
compile time ensuring that potential
issues are addressed before running time
in today's digital age web security is
of utmost importance protecting user
data and ensuring the Integrity of web
applications is a top priority the open
web application security project or oasp
provides guidelines and best practices
to ensure web application security
familiarizing oneself with common
vulnerabilities and their mitigations is
essential for any front-end developer
most web apps require storing and
retrieving data tradition restful apis
come with limitations especially when
dealing with complex data structures
graphql emerges as a powerful
alternative offering more flexibility in
querying data graphql allows clients to
request only the data they need reducing
over fetching it provides a more
efficient powerful and flexible
alternative to the traditional rest API
building server rendered react
applications can be streamlined with the
right framework nextjs is a leading
Choice offering features that enhance
performance and developer experience
nextjs provides automatic code splitting
server side rendering and a rich set of
features that make building scalable
react applications a breeze the Astro
web framework introduces a unique
approach to building faster websites
Astro allows developers to deliver less
JavaScript by default resulting in
Faster load times it offers partial
hydration and integrates with various
modern Frameworks ensuring Flex abbility
and performance a well-designed website
is not just about Aesthetics performance
plays a crucial role in user experience
in search engine rankings adhering to
best practices like optimizing images
leveraging browser caching and
minimizing server response times can
significantly boost website performance
regular audits using tools like Google's
Lighthouse can provide insights and
recommendations the world is
increasingly mobile and developers need
tools to build crossplatform mobile
applications efficiently react native is
a framework that allows for the
development of native mobile apps using
react with react native developers can
write most of their applications code
once and run it on both IOS and Android
it offers a rich set of components and
Native modules ensuring that apps feel
truly native front end development is a
dynamic and ever evolving field as te
techologies emerge and best practices
evolve staying updated and adaptable is
key this road map provides a foundation
but the Journey of learning and
exploration is endless there are plenty
of popular tools that were left off this
road map and I'm sure there are already
many comments under this video letting
us know that we left out their favorite
framework or technology but you have to
start somewhere and the items I listed
here are a good place to start engage
with the community experiment with new
tools and always strive for excellence
the world of frontend development offers
endless possibilities and with the right
tools and knowledge you can craft
exceptional web experiences so good luck
on your Learning Journey